he just feels our audiences are
perfectly matched his idea was to create
something in town for Commodore and so
because the concept is you guys shoot
the creation of the ultimate cosplay
walk-around robot so we got YouTube
involved they were all like oh my gosh
this is great we're in this is going to
be the unofficial mascot of geek week
that and the colleagues over at Wired
wanted to do the ultimate cosplay so
would we be interested in playing with
them and helping to create this
character and of course the answer is
like yeah why not go to comic-con with
something that we create here that we
normally do for TV film commercials and
then bring it to the general population
that's fantastic we rarely get to share
what we do especially in this level of
detail that the Winston school was going
to create to me it's really exciting to
be able to watch it go from inception
all the way to finish we we've never
done that before
we hope that we inspire people to go and
do some stuff go make a cosplay costume
like come out next year and give us a
run for our money you know make it
awesome this is what we're celebrating I
think the reaction to this is
yeah pretty shocked and it's in like I
said in person it's a whole nother
animal